- On this episode, stick with me here,
we go to the gym with me.
(hip hop music)
♫ You ask questions
♫ And I answer them
♫ This is the #AskGaryVee Show
This is so ridiculous!
This, this is so ridiculous. (laughs)
- [Gary] Ready?
- [Staphon] Yep.
- Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 163
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
It's a little bit of a ridiculous show.
I'm even regretting it as
we're doing this right now.
We'll try to get through this.
Yeah, so I had to get my workout in,
I just landed from LA and I really wanted
to do the show today, I was
like in a good good mood for it,
and I was on WIFI and DeMayo's like
you're not gonna fit it in,
and I'm like, well, just
send them to the gym!
So Mike's here, we're gonna
answer some questions India,
so let's, show India, India's here
at the gym with me, it's so ridiculous.
And DRock's gonna hate this episode,
I mean, I literally look like
I'm in a dungeon somewhere, trapped.
So India, let's get into the show.
- [Voiceover] Um first, first one...
- Just brushed my teeth, it's disgusting.
- [India] From Chad.
- Yeah?
- [Voiceover] Chad asks,
"So... the Square IPO.
"What are your thoughts on the future
"of mobile credit services?"
- Yeah, I think that um, (laughs)
this is, I mean, there's a
vine out there by the way
of me like on the toilet, I
don't know if people know this.
But this is starting to
feel like a really bad idea.
I think that, I think the
wallet will be eliminated
and that we will all pay
with our mobile devices,
maybe with our fingerprints,
but the wallet is antiquated,
it's like a magazine, it's
like carving in the caves.
And I think over the next 10 years
technology will be really in a place
where we can go full throttle
on electronic payments.
Obviously there's the Blockchain
and all that world with bitcoin.
There's also the fact
of my historic behavior.
Four years ago, maybe five,
I invested in Venmo, maybe six.
So I've been on this kick for a while,
I'm big believer, and
I think with Apple Pay
you're seeing more behavior around this
and I'm extremely bullish,
so if you're playing
in a space that is like, you
make portraits for wallets
or you make wallets, that's something
to be concerned about
over the next decade,
and even on the flip
side, if you can support
an ecosystem where people
don't carry wallets,
so like, what's the chatchka
that needs to be made,
in a world where your phone
is really your payment thing,
so like, what's the official Beats by Dre
license carrier with the
phone 36 months from now
that like is the hot shit that
everybody's got on the 'Gram
or whatever anybody's paying
attention to in 36 months,
that's where I'd be using this wave
as an entrepreneurial venture opportunity.
- [Mike] Let's get your upper back.
- Oh yeah, we gotta respect
Mike in this scenario.
- Upper back.
- Where? The wall?
- No, no, right here, just
lay on it this way, good.
Good, butt on the ground.
- Yeah, oh this.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Alright, go ahead.
- [India] Alright, from Rupa.
- Rupa!
- [Voiceover] Rupa asks,
"I have a startup idea
"to improve women's underwear.
"I'm scratching my own itch, but
know nobody in the business.
"Advice?"
- So India, you and I
worked on this one today
we saw this tweet, I sent it to you,
you went to go reach out to her.
She deleted it, what did she say?
- [India] She said oh
yeah, I just deleted it,
but I'll put it back up right
now if you're gonna pick it.
- (Gary laughs) I love it.
Mike, this is starting to
get good, look at that.
- [Mike] Yeah I know, thoracic extension.
- Um, one more, we'll just bend this out.
Rupa, I think that this answer
is actually the answer to your question,
which is, you don't know me,
hey Rupa, you don't know me!
You don't know me, and you tweeted at me,
and here I am responding to
you and giving you feedback,
in the same way that you can go and map
all 700 executives in the industry
and hit them up on Twitter and say hello,
I'd like to talk to you
about my business idea,
and literally three of them will say yes,
two of them will cancel on you,
and one out of the 700 people,
and if you think about three
to five minutes per engagement,
three minutes to write the engagement
and kinda to check it, and
then maybe four to 10 hours
of research of who those
700 executives are,
that you need for marketing or production
or the retail world, right?
Like, as you've tried to, (laughs)
this is so, this is the most,
this is way up there with
ridiculous things that I've done.
I'm so sorry to the Vayner Nation.
I don't know what I decided, I
don't know how this happened.
Anyway, I think that um,
I like take my workout serious too.
So, I think you have
to go and reach out to,
and so I'm telling you
that you're gonna get
to one person, maybe two, by spending 80,
90 hours of time, which scares
way too many of you off.
The problem is, what's the alternative?
The problem is, what is the alternative?
When you're at the bottom
and you've got nothing,
you've gotta scrap, it's like me and Mike
when we first, now I can use this,
now I'm gonna start using this gym.
When we first started here 16 months ago
Mike told me to do this,
this, and I couldn't do it.
I couldn't do it!
That's how at the bottom physically I was,
and then we just
systematically did things.
That whole thing when I
was like this is good,
literally 60 days ago I
couldn't do crap with that
because we hadn't worked
on that flexibility.
So, anyway, what you have to do
is you have to find the 700 people
and you have to go and get them.
And I would use Twitter,
LinkedIn is a place
you could use as well, the problem is
so many people spam on LinkedIn
you get so much more upside on Twitter
especially if you don't
just like spam them
with the first move, you know,
jab jab and right hooking.
Woops, I use the wrong, anyway!
So that's it, put in the work.
Put in the work!
- [India] Shawn, I was asked to fill out-
- Hold on one second India.
I gotta take this as the priority.
- [Mike] Just warmin' up on the curls.
- Curls?
- [Mike] Yep.
- Oh crap, we're doing arm
day, like the thing I'm weak,
this is where I get exposed
for the thing I'm weakest at.
- [Mike] You curl 40s, that's
like, any fitness people
that watch will be like, curling
40s is really impressive.
- Yeah? Well cool.
'Cause let me show you
what I started with.
(laughs) I was like oh Mike,
this is never gonna happen.
Nah, but we started, but
by the way, this was real!
And it was like, my biceps
have been hard for me.
My tri's have been good.
- [Mike] Tri's are good.
- I will, okay go ahead India.
- [India] From Shawn.
- [Voiceover] Shawn asks, "I was
asked to fill out a self-evaluation,
"but I think these are just a waste of time
"and don't help that much.
"What do you think?"
- I think it depends on
who's on the receiving end
of the self-evaluation.
There are things that
I've done in my career
where I've asked employees to do things
and never then read it,
and that was obviously a waste of time.
(laughs) Right?
And that's not fun for me to admit,
but things that I learned
as a kid at Wine Library
and the truth is even at VaynerMedia
there's been things that I've done.
A lot of my employees
now know, let's do it
on a call for two minutes
instead of emailing me
'cause that's not how I roll.
If somebody's on the other
end listening to that feedback
and actually does something
with that feedback,
the self-evaluation is tremendous.
I think you're barking up
the right tree, though,
is I don't think that's happening
in 99% of organizations.
mainly 'cause the intent
isn't there to give a crap
enough about the employee, and
so my cynical point of view
of how businesses are
treating their employees
leads me to, you're probably right.
Now, if you're there because you believe,
I'd like to think that India feels good
about doing it at VaynerMedia with me
on my team, so then it's valuable.
But I think it comes down to more about
how much you believe in the organization,
more so than the tactic that is deployed
in a self-evaluation.
I also think people are full
of crap in self-evaluations,
like you're always gonna give yourself,
if it's 50-50 if you're
like am I good or great?
Great!
Am I lazy or just solid? I'm solid!
So like everybody's always leaning
to their best benefit, it's human nature.
- [India] Really, you think everybody is?
- No, I think that's a good point India,
I do think some people are
stunningly hard on themselves.
But yes, I think, you know, first of all
it's a good opportunity,
I never think anything's
a hundred percent, the
hell's a hundred percent?
Nothing.
But yes, I do think the far majority,
and 94%, which allows me to say everybody.
What do you want?
- [Mike] Diamond pushups, 15, body weight.
(Gary blows a raspberry)
- I can do these.
Bang these out!
Alright, go ahead.
Get down here Staphon, I
want you to work with me.
- [Voiceover] Vincent asks, "If
you were gonna start a restaurant
"in the world we live in now,
how would you go about it?"
- Well I think Maple, a
startup I invested in,
Mike I'm not counting,
is doing it, which is,
it's a restaurant in New York City
that doesn't have a
place to actually go in.
So it realizes that by
percentage if you play the math,
especially in New York City if
I was to open it in New York,
your economics are so much
better being a delivery company
than actually having the
overhead of the restaurant.
This is something I think
about a lot with Wine Library,
which is a bricks and clicks organization.
We have a lot of overhead to
run the store versus the dotcom
and that's how much energy
you wanna put against it,
so I'd probably launch a restaurant
that was very unique in
the way that it served
patrons locally in a physical
restaurant environment,
maybe open on Saturday's only,
and then the rest was delivery.
Something clever, something
that gave it pizazz
based on when I was open, and then,
and then the delivery
would be the backbone
and the infrastructure,
in a New York environment.
Somewhere else, I'd probably go for,
I'd find an amazing chef and go for,
like, porridge, it's what
I brought up the other day.
I'd try to win on
something that other people
aren't doing a bunch of, like,
obviously tacos and premium burgers,
I still don't think
there's a hot dog winner.
You know, it feels like there's somebody
that can win the
shake-shack hotdog game, so.
- [Voiceover] Chris asks, "is
it more effective to market
"your humble self or a
caricature of yourself
"in today's service-based tech industry?"
- Chris, the best thing
to do, this is a good time
to answer this question.
The best way to do anything
is to be the truth.
So sometimes I'm humble, and
sometimes I'm egotistical,
and sometimes I'm ridiculous.
And this would be one of those times.
I think your honest self
is always the right answer.
If you're trying to play to
what the market likes right now,
you're gonna always have to change, right?
Right now entrepreneurship is cool.
By the way, when the tech bubble bursts,
when, God forbid, and I haven't
been able to send my love
to a lot of my business
associates that live
in the Paris area, obviously
grew up in the wine business,
know a lot of people in that town,
and so God forbid when that, when, not if,
when that happens in the
US and the market pops,
entrepreneurship's not gonna be hot.
Practical, paying your
bills is gonna get hot.
We've had a great 10 year run
here that everybody's kinda
living in right now,
and all you youngsters
haven't really tasted the alternative,
you haven't tasted the stock
market splitting in half,
jobs not being available,
you not getting recruited
by everybody, your
homies from school saying
come start a business with me.
Practicality is really
on the horizon, I see it.
Oh, there you are practicality!
It's coming, and when it comes
it's going to be an
interesting market change.
This show, hopefully I'm
doing it when it happens.
Well, hopefully I'm not,
hopefully it doesn't
happen for awhile, but.
I think you have to be you,
because I was entrepreneur
when it wasn't sexy, I'm entrepreneur now,
and I promise you, and I'll
play this clip 22 years from now
I will be entrepreneur
when it's not sexy again.
(India mumbles)
Awesome.
- [Mike] We gotta get the
40s on camera for sure.
- Okay.
- [Mike] 40's is diesel.
- Okay, cool, I'm excited, oh Jesus!
- [Mike] Hammer to underhand.
- Mike!
Alright, question of the day:
What's going on with your workout regimen?
Where are you in your
process with your thing?
India, where are you at?
- Uh, yeah, I'm doing good.
You know, I fell off the
wagon a little bit, but...
- Maintaining the lean strength.
- Maintaining the lean strength, yes.
- You keep asking
questions, (India laughs)
Mike will keep making me lift weights.
See you guys later, thanks for watching!
DRock, eat it, bad lighting.
That's it? I did one extra?
See ya!
(upbeat hip hop music)